yeah we're good to go chin look at us
just the boys just the boys the original
teams back together and this is a good
way to start this because we're gonna
this I'm calling this podcast the Hammer
Of Truth
and in and I'm I'm gonna start this off
by by saying a couple things right
seriously yeah because because
I believe when the chaos hits you tell
the truth I've always been honest with
everybody all the fans and everybody
listens
uh
Bobby uh Bobby Lee is somebody I love
very much we both do yes but Bobby but
people have been talking on uh he he
went online and he he went on and talked
about somebody who spoke to him in a
very rough bullying manner okay that
wasn't anybody but me I'm the guy I'm
the one who did it not not Chris not
Theo not Sam it was me okay and the re
and now now here's the second thing I
want to say Bobby is 100 right in his
anger at me in his in how he felt and
I'm 100 wrong I take full [ __ ]
responsibility for the way I spoke to
him which was wrong there's no excuse
okay
and and now I will give you now having
said that let me say it again this is
what I said to Bobby Bobby when did you
talk I spoke to Bobby I tried to speak
to him after you spoke to kalila when I
spoke to Bobby I said to him on the
phone I believe you
and then I thought I don't know I
thought that she was and and let me just
say this and I'm gonna I'm gonna explain
this but I want to First own up to
everything that I did because what I did
at the end of the day the way I spoke to
Bobby who's somebody I love who didn't
deserve the way nobody deserves to be
just attacked and I'm going to tell you
where I was wrong and I'm going to get
specific but let me start once again by
saying me I'm the guy okay I take full
responsibility I was wrong I said this
to Bobby I called him up and Bobby read
me the riot act I think if he had been
in front of me he would have [ __ ]
punched me and and he's Justified and I
said Bobby you're absolutely right I
apologize I was wrong
and where I was wrong was this I didn't
give Bobby the benefit of the doubt I
didn't ask him first I didn't really
give him the respect to say hey dude is
what I'm seeing true
so let me get into that
um I this had nothing to do nothing to
do with you and the kalila thing I'm
nothing this had not I don't get
involved I wasn't there I don't get
involved with any of that it just
happened a lot there was something else
so I want to make hold on real quick
with the timeline with the kalila stuff
and then what you're going to refer to
you're looking about
three to five weeks yes difference I did
not coincidence I did not know I I you
never talk about it and it did you know
this we're very close but think about
this I didn't know that for six years
you've been getting
crazy not just hate there is a
difference guys between hate between
making fun of somebody and threats
threats and harassment long-term
harassment and physical threats against
somebody's family
interference in someone's business and
trying to destroy someone's business
that is there is a very big difference
between real physical and cyber threats
and and and uh and actual harassment
long-term harassment and just hate
people making videos that's all good
dude that's that's the internet that's
that's the internet but what I deal with
I didn't know that I didn't know that I
don't talk about it when I so when so
what happens guys is when you have a
legal matter when it becomes actually
physically dangerous or at least that
would be the when I look at it that's a
very the amount of [ __ ] you take is
actually dangerous correct it's
dangerous there are people that are not
they're not this is not satire this is
not hate this is not a hater this is not
uh somebody being you know funny and
it's out there there's some funny hate
out there you know I look at it
but we're talking about actual
illegal activity correct so what you do
in that situation after six years when
it gets crazy and scary is you hire
professional legal counsel and
professional tonight to deal with it can
I say somebody yes so obviously I don't
talk about the the negative stuff I and
you you know me better than
anyone I don't know anyone your brother
knows you better maybe maybe you're up
there maybe but you know I always look
at life uh as the glass half full always
it's just my nature and I know that
stuff is out there and I've always been
privy to ignore it obviously you know
especially the way I look and having the
careers that I've had it's going to
trigger people and I get all that I 100
get all that and I'm sorry I can't do
anything about that but then you know it
gets to a certain point and when they
step over the the boundaries of
criticism your physical safety correct
and your family's physical safety but
and that you know and that for sure but
then also going after my businesses
companies I'm associated with then then
you're talking about a legal activity
but then but then even with all that
I've never brought it up to you guys
ever man I've never heard about it I
didn't hear about it until until got so
crazy that you had ever but it got so
crazy and the way it works is
one of the reasons I'm at where I'm at
whether you think I'm successful or not
that's Up For Debate is I surround
myself with much smarter people you mark
catch and everybody in here smart me
I'll give you that that's fine
people outside of this that work and
have this engine going my career going
are much Farm me whether my business
manager my agents my managers I
constantly surround myself with smarter
people
I don't deal with any of that stuff
being a stand-up comic and you know this
better than anybody is so tough It's so
tough never happens so my energy goes to
that and my kids that's it man
for me to get notified
that some illegal activities going on
and that I should do something about it
it has to be so bad to the point so bad
that this account got alerted so let me
hold on hold on hold on let me finish
this because it's very important but let
me but let me say this too I know I'm
6'4 250 pounds 255. I know I'm 255
pounds I know I look like this stuff
doesn't bother me it hurts my feelings
man it always has to say it always has
to say the least I don't talk about it
yeah nobody wants me to come on here and
talk about you know how my feelings are
hurt because that's not the masking
thing to do but I'm telling you now so
all you guys know it hurts my feelings
more than you know and that's why I'm
not on social media I didn't leave
social media because you don't think I
want to see my friends and family and
other comics and pairs post stuff and
stuff like that no I I love that stuff I
left because it was so toxic it was so
evil that I don't want to subscribe to
anymore and a lot of people can handle
social media God bless you man I wish I
could I'm too sensitive so I know
because I look like this you guys think
it's okay and doesn't bother me yes it
really hurts my so this is where so this
is what happened
so when I saw the evidence people who
are professionals that they said there
is long-term harassment and essentially
you know more than just more than just
hate coming from X Y Z
when I saw I didn't make this stuff up
when I saw with my own eyes that X some
of that long-term ex-h harassment was
coming from the tiger belly hub
okay and that's what I saw with my own
eyes
when I saw that I went into protection
mode I'm a very protective person that's
my brother I might be too protective and
we're going to get into that too I might
I've been too protective probably it's
not my place to be protective but I am
I'm a ride or die [ __ ] now I so what I
did was I went into protection mode I
saw red and I assumed the worst about
Bobby and about kalila after speaking to
Bobby I realized I really believe that
he has nothing to do with it I don't
think he even knows anything about it I
believe him and I said that on the phone
I said I believe you Bobby and what and
what I and what I tell you B when I
spoke
let me do it then you spoke to kalila
and you called me right away and he said
dude I believe her I don't think kalila
or Bobby have anything to do with this
so then what I did was I called Bobby
this is this is I don't know a week ago
more than that or 10 days ago I called
Bobby he didn't answer I called him the
next day he didn't answer and I got it I
was like he's he must be so pissed off
at me he must have been so pissed off
because once again let me say this the
way I spoke to Bobby is unacceptable the
way I spoke to Bobby and he said
something to me that re that I I haven't
I'll never forget he said I've been
bullied by guys like you my whole life
and it stops now
I'm not a bully but I but if he said
that he was [ __ ] right he was right I
own it I was outside myself and when you
[ __ ] up and I [ __ ] up like that I'm
gonna take ownership okay it doesn't
matter how angry I was it doesn't matter
that I was protecting him it's like it's
like when I thought I was thinking about
this sometimes you don't you don't get a
pass it's like a guy who beats his wife
and then you go you beat your wife and
the guy goes I know dude but she makes
me so angry not an excuse that's not
right not a [ __ ] excuse so I gotta be
fair to yourself I appreciate you on MB
I'm sure they appreciate it but you vote
you've always defended me and I've also
always defended you yes it's what we do
it's what I do dude I go to the mat you
know you know we've been in situations
even physical situations where there
were a bunch of very dangerous people
and I was like you know you were down
they were I was down I wasn't down I
know you were they were real guys who
you were afraid we're gonna fight you or
come at you and I said hey dude I'm I
for me I'm I'm needing you with you
[ __ ] I I I'm not a tough guy but
I'll I'm I'm not leaving yourself I
reciprocated that when I know you went
through yourself so that's how it is
that's how that's what we do okay
doesn't mean I handled it right I didn't
once again once again I'm gonna say this
to what I said to Bobby Bobby you are
100 right I was 100 wrong okay well
puppy but I also think it's fair to say
so I don't think I don't think we
handled any of this right no no I was
too upset and I was so upset I was I was
so I was so and I said to him I said
call me buddy wanted to apologize I said
that April 29th 29th um our 25th
yeah 28th I'm old I can't read April
25th
28th I said Earth fifth I said at 2 51 I
said call me buddy wanted to apologize
okay and then I and here I really I'm
sorry I said then after that I said
after we spoke after we spoke I sent him
a text I really am sorry Bobby you're
Justified and I was wrong no excuses I
love you and I wish you well I'll always
I'll also make it up to you one day if I
can you'll see that's what I said those
are my text to Bobby you guys go back
how many years I love him for Mad TV I
love how long I love him and and he
didn't deserve it and and
I have to live with that I was I was
being protective over you and I and I
saw red because I because I had seen I
had been steeped and I had seen how
horrible this stuff was I'd seen the
threats I'd seen the physical dangerous
the the difference between hate and and
true harassment and and violence and and
I and I and I and I guess I went a
little crazy but to to be Fair again I'm
not condoning in you know and obviously
we both apologize the way you spoke to
Bobby but
you know I I think if anybody saw that
kind of abuse and the negativity and
then for their team I'm not saying Bobby
and Clyde for them to be associated with
it I was so hurt you don't understand I
know that because I because I understand
so relieved when I found when I when I
believed it and you know Bobby and I
spoke I apologized and he accepted my
apology but he also said I don't want to
talk to you dude and that that's and I
deserve it that's fair I hope someday I
can I [ __ ] hope someday I might see
him at something I hope when I see him
maybe I can hug him and hold him until
he forgives me or maybe I can or maybe I
can make it up to him I was like you
know maybe maybe Bobby hey Bobby maybe
you could tattoo something on me and and
that way we can be friends whatever I
got to do this whole thing has gotten
out of control though because there's
love between I love us Bobby he doesn't
know he doesn't and I get it I I [ __ ]
hurt him and I I just think he was
mishandled all the way around it's
gotten to the point where we have to
address it which you know me I don't
like addressing this stuff the world
yeah I mean sometimes you have to tell
the truth and when I [ __ ] up I own it
when I [ __ ] up you know I I don't have
any problem telling the truth and I
don't have any problem you know uh
owning up to and facing up to when I
when I am outside myself no and I
appreciate that b but but I also think
you know I'm going on tigerbelly to
address it too it's like and I think Bob
and Clyde will also own up and Clio said
this because you know their email is
associated with this and there's other
stuff associated with well it's an
ongoing investigation I will say this
guys I will say this
is what I heard from what I what I can
only accept is a reliable source I'm not
a tech guy I don't do this stuff I don't
know anything about this but what I
heard reliably from what I believe is a
reliable source is since we have
confronted them and I'm I'm not saying
that Bobby or kalila know anything about
this or have any I truly believe they
don't have anything to do with it but
somebody on their team does well the
harassment the posts stopped from that
account and that account got changed and
that's going to be brought up on
tigerbelly okay and we're just being
honest this drama I'm way too old to
deal with it but but I [ __ ] up and so
once again here's what I have to say I'm
the guy director hated me I take full
responsibility Bobby I love you I'm
sorry I was wrong I was 100 wrong you
didn't deserve that I should have given
you the benefit of the doubt I should
have spoken to you first how the [ __ ]
did I think a guy as sweet as you as
special as you as giving as you as funny
as you would ever do something like that
I I how would I think that I got [ __ ]
deranged I was listening and I I didn't
do my due diligence I didn't which is
unlike you it's unlike me but I was so
trauma was so [ __ ] traumatized
because I've never told you about it but
then I started talking about I got
scared I got scared dude when I get
scared I fight I know you do you know I
I don't I don't I don't [ __ ] back
down I'm gonna fight but here you got to
be careful about how you fight agree but
here's the way this thing ends is
there's obviously love between us and
tiger belly and I'm gonna go on there
and say my truth and they're gonna say
how we hurt them and that's fine and
hopefully we can squash all of it and
even Kyla goes all right well if we find
out who it is what he wants to do
and this this goes for anybody out there
I I told client Bobby I just want to
stop I I want nothing else I'm there's
no legal action there's no threats
I will have to say this too I have to
say this
i i in the midst of my anger and my my
hurt and the way I was speaking and I
know Bobby feels differently because of
the way I spoke I would never
ever
do anything to him ever in a million
[ __ ] years never not physically and
not career-wise or anything neither one
no but it doesn't matter man because I
gotta own what the [ __ ] I did and how
roughly I spoke don't remember all the
details but I was mad and I was upset
and I was protecting my friend Yep this
is a teaching moment for anybody younger
listen take a minute when you're really
upset when you feel like you're
Justified when you feel like you're
being attacked take a [ __ ] minute
think think I'm way too old to have
behaved the way I did I'd say take
longer in a minute take long also I
think give your friends the benefit of
the doubt especially someone as
wonderful as Bobby yeah sweet as Bobby
and I hope someday I can I can I can
mend that friendship but I don't deserve
it right now yeah and I'm gonna talk
about it to Bobby today and just
hopefully I can be the guy that connects
you guys and get you guys back together
yeah but but I also think too is through
all this I think you know I've obviously
made mistakes too the way I handled it
with kalila not so it's really not Bobby
it's more me and a kalila thing and
what I learned you know I don't know her
that well but even though I don't know
her is I sure went directly to her yes
instead of going anywhere else are you
saying getting your [ __ ] in line though
this was this was not bad that was how
it was characterized I just had nothing
to do with for me it had nothing to do
with kalala it had nothing to do with it
had this had to do with seeing that
long-term harassment according to these
sources said it's coming one of the main
sources is coming from there and I went
what but but I want our fans to realize
how toxic that group is right now if you
have any doubts if you have any doubts
go look at it yeah they're radicalized
but then also go look at you know the
reason that the account got flagged in
the first place for for it to get to me
a guy who ignores it for it because it
hurts my feelings I'm because I'm better
than social media Reddit groups the
reason it got notified is because
there's a video of this man beating his
son who is six years old with autism
that's when it crossed that that's what
you're dealing that's when you realize
who these some of these people are so
dumb not all some a majority of them and
then the the main five six counts that
are doing a lot of this harassment over
the top criminal activity
they look in their background it's an
ongoing investigation there's pedophiles
there's horrible stuff in that so let's
this is this is not something you want
to be very generous about that because
that's what I'm doing yeah but I just
want you to realize that this goes be
you want to criticize my comedy my stand
up my fight picks uh the way you and I
engage yeah have at it man sure but and
there is stuff to criticize there this
we're going to make this that's the
world we live in I've been too
protective of this guy you know he does
interrupt he does [ __ ] you know talk
down sometimes he he does behave in an
arrogant way which is the defense
mechanism for him it just is but we're
gonna get back to [ __ ] man we're gonna
you know I said to him I go we gotta get
back to getting you and I having
conversations that are go beyond
ourselves [ __ ] picking up on [ __ ]
rhythms
what a good time to do it because you
know Chappelle went off on his own he's
building his podcast and he's headlined
his own shows and so now it's just it's
back to the original crew yeah and I'm
so excited for it you see the new
thumbnail we have new intro coming so
they're going to be better timing dude
can I get better as a podcast even
though I've been doing for 10 years and
I have my 10 000 hours 100 do I make
mistakes are you kidding me you can get
better I make all the mistakes and stand
up he said everything with the pie with
the special he he called me and he goes
I just I just all I wanted to do was
just
show myself and the people close to me
that I've gotten better that I've been
working at this it's so [ __ ] hard
stand up is the hardest job it's so hard
and and and you know hey and you know
it's a the hardest job in the world but
B to do a special dude on your own and
rely on your team then we have to deal
with all the the marketing and the all
that stuff with it like I didn't realize
what an animal it is it was such a beast
it's all one continuous mistake and so
is life you know I made a mistake I will
pay for that and I will do everything I
can to make it up to somebody I love
named Bobby Lee and and I've only met
kalila once but she didn't deserve that
[ __ ] either so uh she seems like a great
person from what I could tell she seems
like a very fair good person well and
I'm gonna tell her this to her in her
face I told her this on the phone
dude you want to talk about a smart
educated like I told like we got done
but we said some things we both probably
didn't mean then we finally got through
that and really had some growth and I
told her I went man I know you do this
podcast thing you're crushing if you
ever want to be a lawyer you would crash
it I'm Savage yeah Savage yeah and so in
a good way yeah and I hope that I hope
that uh I hope I can get some uh anyway
that's all I have to say I take
responsibility and let's move on after
this and hopefully I can go on tigerbell
and we squash all this because what I
don't like to do is the clickbaity drama
pot I don't like that it doesn't make me
feel it's not what I want to do well
especially I'd rather have people that
I'd rather have 50 views than a million
and deal with this negativity all the
time it's not what I do I don't want to
do that it's not what we do it's not
what I do let me button this up we're
gonna put this to bed right now we got
other stuff to cover we got this is a
big podcast we got a lot of [ __ ] to
cover it's Cat's last day cats last day
my last day I feel like I'm graduating I
feel like everybody's jumping [ __ ] yeah
um no it's Cat's last day then Christian
got a new job full-time gig he moved on
yep let me button this up let me say
this one more time so there's no
confusion Bobby I'm sorry you were 100
right I was 100 wrong there are no
excuses there are no excuses with the
way I spoke to you you didn't deserve it
and I I apologize unreservedly I was an
[ __ ] I was not the guy I want to be
and I deserve the criticism so if you
guys want to hate me bring it I deserve
it and I agree and that's all that's the
best I can do I'm sorry I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to do better always and I'll
always be [ __ ] honest with you guys I
will always own up to my [ __ ] and I
and and because I can't sleep otherwise
I don't live I don't live my life
otherwise no all this so thank God Bobby
accepted my apology but he's [ __ ]
angry and he deserves this is gonna take
time brother and then I'm gonna talk to
him today
yeah I know who doesn't love them yeah I
know he's the best man he's always been
so nice to me now now let's get into a
podcast a chin I'd like to get I'd like
to just iron out one little detail if I
could may I let me I don't know chin
Play a clip for me so I can [ __ ] have
a little conversation with Brendan and
all right put that to bed too so Brian
sent me a clip I have not looked at it
but he did a little uh he did he did
schultzy's podcast yeah go ahead let's
now Eminem
what's up go ahead play it you know in
the UFC in the NFL college football I
wish I had someone that with the respect
of that now that goes whoa dude we've
been doing two years yeah nobody tell
you until you're 10 years did nobody say
that to you no not really because I
think see I said not really shut up
there's some leeway shut the [ __ ] up he
was like yo let me watch it or let me
just hey man it takes [ __ ] you can't
cheat this game it takes [ __ ] years
to get to the point where you can do
this you're calling a little bit a
little bit delete a little bit a little
bit more like see there's some leeway
there there's some wig all right stop
I did give you a little credit you
wanted all the credit well listen this
is the Hammer Of Truth this podcast is
the Hammer Of Truth oh yeah right we're
we're talking truth here
[ __ ] you and I got a almost a
physical fight over here I sat you down
I had an intervention we were in San
Francisco we almost got into physical
fight I was good I was willing to take a
beating yeah I was like you're gonna do
a special yes you're not ready not ready
and this is insane you got you thought I
was jealous for a second you got outside
your head you were 100 you're insecure
no but but I said I had my friend my
dear friend tarek and Tara goes hey he's
a black belt you're still a white belt
you might want to listen to him you were
like Jay was there too yup Jay was there
too but B can I defend myself here no
not yet I'm not done hold on hold sir
keep going you need to take your go
ahead you need to take a punch in the
face here go ahead
I begged you not to do it you did I was
I said I even said I'll take three
months and write I'll write with you
I'll make the just please don't do this
you're not ready please don't yep and
you didn't listen to me and then after
you got all that hate after the special
edition you send me a text you sent me a
text you go I was crazy Brian see what I
love about you is you admit when you're
wrong and you do you always do oh yeah
you come you sleep on it you I get a
text from Brennan he was getting all
this hate from our peers from other
Comics which I knew was gonna happen I
knew was gonna happen and he got and I
got a text and it said dude you were
trying to save me from all this I wish
I'd listened to you what was wrong with
me and but I learned I always I always
have to take the hardest road yeah what
I do I know and here's the thing with
that uh Showtime special is my only goal
in this life is to be like you guys
that's all I want to do man I know and I
didn't have the perspective back then I
thought by having a special on a major
Network I'm like you guys I didn't have
the perspective go no no it's gonna make
it worse for you yeah you're you're not
like them by doing this they've worked
10 years to even get 20 years some 20
but some let's say 10 10 20 years
minimum to get something like this and
it's going to make you're gonna have a
bullseye in your back if you do this
Brennan and I thought well I don't
obviously the fans and the the hate
which I was especially again back then
you know that grew but it's like I
thought I don't care about any of that
stuff but my peers and the comics are
like he's on Showtime he's good that's
not the way this game works it just
doesn't work that way and I again I have
to learn the hardest way yes and I
apologize you at the time and you've
always been the one const in my life
that wants the very best for me but I
learned the hardest way but I do I
learned the hardest way you do it's what
I do you do I go you got I run into that
wall and so it [ __ ] moves but it's my
life story yeah what's the hard to walk
on to division one football team that's
the hardest I'll do that you've seen
lots of training fighting the UFC after
18 months training 18 months I'll do
that uh do stand-up comedy and then
shoot a special with two years of
headlining one year I'll do one year
basically two years finding the kid but
in one year one year yeah but I I'll do
that so it's like there's this I was
like that in the history of the world
but I guess I guess this is common theme
man you know so look you live and you
learn brother you you yeah you're too
tough for your own good you're too
[ __ ] you're too stubborn for your own
good sometimes sometimes you suffer from
a little arrogance no no see I think
that's where people get confused I think
that that there's a stupidity no no
there might be some stupid there's it's
not that it's not stupid it's not
arrogance I don't believe on in any
facet I'm as good as you or should
billboard in any facet my only goal is
to get the respect from you guys yeah
and every move I make is to do that I
want to say when you go to work ethic or
any of that stuff that's why I work so
hard
for the fans that pay to see the show
but it's also for you guys go he's not
taking Instagram yeah he he's not just
going through the motions to sell take
it yes no and I want to say this about
you I just beat you up a little bit I
want to say this about you and I really
mean this
um look I know I will always defend you
I will go to the mat for you I will
always I don't give a [ __ ] it's like
it's like like I showed you that one
time when those very dangerous people
were thinking about and you would know
who they were were thinking about
fighting you I think it was six of them
and it was just you no no don't say it
don't say it don't say it no I don't
want and I didn't want it I don't even
want to [ __ ] put that out can you say
nope don't even say that please don't
even say that beep those two things out
and let them but but either way I don't
want to even get into that but I
remember no problem no I go it's six of
them I want to be there and it's really
you and then this guy yeah but for me I
was like if I Gotta Die
with you here then that's how I Define
friendship and so for me and the reason
I feel that way about you Brennan and
for all you people who can't stand
Brennan have an opinion you don't know
him and everybody that knows him he's a
flawed guy yeah he is he's a flawed
[ __ ] guy a lot of things aren't we
all but but I will say this everyone you
know from Rogan to Schultz to to
DeStefano to me to everyone that knows
Brennan really knows him and I'm talking
about Big Time comics and everybody else
we love him because at his core at his
[ __ ] core he's such a good person and
you know why I know that I know it
instinctually but I know it because of
his actions you guys have no idea how
many people he's helped and he helps
them
for no reason he helps them because he
just can I've seen that and continues
that with my own eyes I have seen him
I'm talking about giving money I'm
talking and nobody ever knows about it
he never tells anybody about it no one
about it there is a reason that so many
New York Comics are have him on the
podcast so many New York Comics come on
this pocket so many New York Comics love
them there's a reason that a lot of
people love the guy and I'm one of them
and I make no apologies for that none I
make no apologies man for loving my
friend because he's worth it and he's a
good person I love you he's a good
person that's everybody yeah so I had to
say that it's very [ __ ] important I
appreciate it man yeah so okay now that
we've done all that now that we've done
all that
um let's uh let's move on this is our
first break let's take a little break
before we continue with this raw because
I I've got to take a break because I'm
going to be in at the DC comedy Loft
this weekend I love Washington DC it's a
fantastic I got Thursday Friday Saturday
shows and then I go right I go right to
my special I'm taping my special May
19th there's still tickets at the Brea
Improv I'm excited for you buddy I'm
excited buddy I'm hitting in all
cylinders and then West Palm Beach
Florida improv May 27 2829. you're where
I'm do next week next week uh next
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm in Philly
one my favorite cities Philadelphia
Pennsylvania May 19th through the 21st
as next Thursday through Saturday with
the thick boy Squad and then I'm in
Portland Oregon June 9th through the
11th San Francisco Cobbs June 17th
through June 18th get your tickets at
thickboy.com Philly see you next week uh
I want to talk about hair loss because
it's well it hits close to home yeah you
you can talk about all the things you
want to do at the end of the day you got
to go to science you got to go to a
company that makes science affordable
I'm talking about keeps yeah my friends
that keeps P.S yes my friends at keeps
and here's the thing man more than 50
million Bros in the US suffer from male
pattern baldness and keeps its simple
affordable stress-free way to keep your
freaking five star reviews dude 24 7
care and support low cost starts just
ten dollars per month they have
everything you need it's delivered
straight to your door discreet little
package all right proven results
prevention is key can take up to four to
six months see results so act right now
it does if you're ready if you're ready
to take action prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com fighter that's
k-e-e-p-s.com fighter receive your first
month of treatment for free that's
keeps.com fighter to get your first
month's free
keeps.com fighter athletic greens you if
you look if you are not getting enough
vegetables and fruits which you are not
if you're not getting enough nutrition
which I guarantee you are not some of
the highest performing people I've ever
met take athletic greens yep and they
swear by it and I've seen it with my own
eyes one tasty scoop of AG one contains
75 vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
ingredients a multivitamin a
multi-mineral a probiotic greens Green
super food blend and More in one and
it's all in one convenient daily serving
and one serving get all that it tastes
delicious I put one scoop in your boy
hits the ground running you do it every
every month every every morning because
being on uh carnivore this guy I gotta I
can't get all my greens I need that
multivitamin it's fantastic all right
join the movement right now to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you immune supporting free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first per first purchase
if you visit athletic greens.com fighter
today no added sugar there's one gram of
sugar no jam it tastes fantastic No
nasty chemicals or artificial anything
and it tastes delicious again simply
visit athletic greens.com fighter take
control of your health and give ad1 a
try athletic greens.com fighter bro you
were missed in New York Bubba was I yeah
I always think about you in New York I
can't believe you kind of came up there
it's such a special song oh my god dude
you can do five sets a night in New York
God man you that's where the grind
happens dude I watched Chris to seveno
special last night how good is it
hilarious best ushi I love him he's the
best he's so funny I went to his house
but he's doing a special and just
[ __ ] around he's improvising I mean
he's you know what Stefano has
he's like this big handsome dude who's
got tremendous vulnerability he's just
so vulnerable and so [ __ ] great man I
I felt so good out there you know with
the flagrant 2 team and then with uh de
Stefano and then by the way I want to
say this is on your side yeah I know I
love Schultz dude these two here yeah
when when you shoot your special you go
to New York
there's this podcast called called are
you garbage and Akash on flagrant 2
because I go hey man this is my schedule
am I missing anything he goes you have
to do are you garbage I don't know them
I knew of them because uh Mark Norm was
on there and Schultz and Tim Dillon and
so I don't know he goes he goes they're
they're getting big but and they're two
guys from the the seller that they got
passed and they're funny man it's
different show you might have fun let me
know if you can do it here's his number
he connects me to Kevin the guy in the
right
before I decide to do it I reached out
to every comic I know in New York
several comics every and again the
respect of your peers is everything
every comic in New York goes these two
are the best they're great comedians
their podcast is the funnest you're
gonna have out here definitely do it so
I tell them hey man my schedule is back
dude and he goes whenever you can do it
we'll make time for I go I can only do
at 8pm on Monday night I do two shows
before that I'll do yours at 8. yeah but
fun yes and they go we're in so me I'm
talking about great guy like that's
weird how nice he is
you do their show and you know you do
we've done a million shows this is
garbage are you garbage so what they are
you guys so this is the form of the show
the formula of the show is they they go
through your childhood and what you the
way you were raised and at the end they
tell if you're garbage we found out I
was garbage three minutes in the way I
was born yeah I was like well should we
end it now and they're laughing so hard
they're so funny it's so different I got
in the taxi that night I got in the tax
that night because they remind me of us
if you remember when we're at Fox Sports
and you could feel there was like what
we had was special and we were coming up
and we knew we were onto something big
and
everybody told you not to do it with me
and you know this podcast this this
podcast stuff is stupid it's going to go
nowhere in Hollywood doing these TV
shows and we do we just ignored all of
it we kept doing it and when I I got in
the car I had tears in my eyes and
they're they're right now they're like
they're just like us on the cusp of
blowing the [ __ ] up and there are two
comics and they all you all they have is
each other and one other guy and I I
text him I said you guys are gonna be so
big man and you guys have something so
original and so special and I've been
there and I'm I suck at this stop and
smell the roses what you guys are doing
and that to leave the next day because
they're doing just like us they're doing
the podcast on the road at Comedy Works
in Denver doing one show Just Like Us
yes and I told him I said dude I'm
telling you you guys can be huge you're
gonna get through making all the money
in the world but what you're doing right
now the come up right now is everything
try to embrace it it's the magic yeah
it's the magic and they're the dude you
know how it is when you meet people
they're just so genuine and like good
people man and you want the best for
them and their Show's so original so fun
Kevin and Foley they're just such good
people yeah the episode just dropped
today and it's so fun man I told them I
said this is the funnest time I've had I
don't know how long ago really you do
broken do I I know but I've done that
before and you know obviously that's a
different kind of dance what you guys do
nobody asked me questions it's always me
promoting something where you and I
[ __ ] around or mean Theo roasting
somebody like for you to dive into my
childhood and then if I'm garbage and
bring up memories I've totally forgot
about I went this is I had so much fun
man it made my [ __ ] trip down made my
trip that's so great yeah it was so fun
yeah that's that magic and it comes down
to loyalty and it comes down to
connection and really what you're
talking about is intimacy that what
happens when you go through
um [ __ ] with somebody over 10 years is
it that you develop a real Bond of
intimacy now some bands break up some
bands can't take it because ego gets in
the way yeah we're not like Aerosmith
where we don't talk anymore we always
[ __ ] air it out we fight we talk but
we are the same we'll be mad for a
minute yeah and after that well we come
back to the truth of the situation right
we come back to was I wrong here yeah
and was I you know you got do that man
you got to do that in Life For Better or
For Worse in your relationships in your
friendships in business and do the right
thing and to defend Bobby like I've been
on the end of your anger when you think
something's going on you if you remember
like remember there was some weird thing
with the money oh boy and you called me
I was like I came after you like you
were like well first of all don't yell
at me holy [ __ ] yeah yeah pretty good at
it yeah betrayal betrayal betrayal is a
tough one yeah yeah yeah it's your
trigger yeah and I was like holy [ __ ]
but then and then we hung up and I was
like holy I tears mama what happened and
then he called me back and then we were
fine yeah you know yeah that's how it
goes yeah but but again hey Brian you
gotta look into things I've had a couple
things in my life I've had I've had
moments in my life where I'm I was just
like I was you know you we all do this
right you do you it's like uh one time I
I did this joke but it was true with my
ex
um we got in a fight and I and I
literally looked at her and I go I have
children with her and I go I want my
plane to crash I hope my plane for real
I hope and I I said a prayer I go I want
it so you can be sad
I want to die I've been there like
that's an outrageous thing to say what
the [ __ ] are you doing but In the Heat
of the Moment I'm just a [ __ ] yeah I
get upset passionate guy yeah yeah but
not an excuse yeah but grow the [ __ ] up
you know you're trying man I'm always
trying yeah we both try yeah now did you
did you see let's get into a little bit
of stuff did you see Mr Canelo lose that
boxing match I yeah I watched it last
night at midnight wow sociopath oh man
me too I watched it after my show on
Saturday yeah I mean you know would he
for him it's tough it was funny because
Jake Paul or somebody was like oh you're
fighting a guy with 3 000 followers and
canelo's like oh bubba this isn't about
social media and Tick Tock come on Jake
this guy's a Monster yeah I didn't know
that monster he's he's is he Russian yes
but what a great fights like Canelo but
obviously he's a natural super
middleware he's bigger so canelo's done
all he can at those lower weights and
now he's moving up and you're gonna run
in some [ __ ] monsters and that was a
monster that's a monster you know like
yeah you don't you guys don't know his
name and I have a tough time pronounce
it there's nothing new there but it's
like before before uh before
he's big you know he's tall he's like
he's such a strong Boxer he fights like
uh he fights just like uh Canelo it
seems but Canelo how great is Canelo
enough take nothing away from that
incredible guy but I mean you're dealing
with a guy who can stand in the pocket
with you right yeah and if you watch the
if you just looked at the scorecards
like oh Canelo you know barely lost that
one you watch like holy [ __ ] he was not
in this fight well that guy is I mean he
is look at how much bigger they're gonna
do a rematch and you know he's a big
super super movie big dude that's it
yeah what is that one fights at 168 170
yeah yeah but you had to realize like
canelo's done all he can so he keeps
going up you eventually you're gonna run
to a guy where not only does he have the
size over he has the same technique yeah
168. yeah so which means he sucks down
to that 175. and cannot tell he wants to
go to you know light heavyweight you
know and all this [ __ ] it's the cruiser
weight it's like why why do you think
and Jake Paul who I respect sure
um because I think he's got balls and I
think he's really working hard at boxing
but he did tell Eddie Hearn that I'll
take anybody on to it he did and he goes
oh cool I have this guy's 1-0 yeah we
fight him and he's a Olympic gold medal
Jake say I'll fight him yeah Jake Jake's
just good at getting things gone yeah
but he knows he's a showman but he's
also in there with good guys so he knows
yeah he knows where he is his next fight
is probably gonna be Tommy Fury and I
think it's in August gen is that right
yeah August 13th against Thomas I'm
watching he's Gonna Knock Out time of
Fury yeah he's [ __ ] strong and he's
got a work ethic but like I like Eddie
her and said you know I was like dude
come on yeah look you're still new to
the game Eddie's funny yeah yeah and
he's like you'll find anybody I got a
guys want to know
Savage yeah yeah
um did you what'd you think of uh the
rosenoma Junius fight uh that was a case
of Rose just having a mental block uh
you know with Carla you know I I think
Rose is the best on the planet if her
mind time for Tony to retire I don't
think so because I yeah I know that's
the the popular thing to say like oh you
know it looks great it looked great
phenomenal you get caught with a up kick
that you didn't expect he I don't think
Chandler's ever thrown that in his life
Charlie goes we don't train that such a
freaky ass
the middle was open I threw it got this
knockout you know and then he called out
Connor which a lot of people want to see
but here's the thing with Connor for my
source what I know he he's not fighting
this year he's not we gotta and again
there's nobody that loves Conor more
than me but he ain't finding this [ __ ]
the ship sailed right now why he's too
big the rehab earliest would be November
if you if there's something to get him
out of retire uh you know what he's
trying to do he is but I don't think he
has any intentions in fighting even
Dana's kind of alluded to that yeah so
the fighting away somehow why not
Chandler uh Nate Diaz a 70. Chandler
says he wants to fight at 70 he'll fight
Connor at 70. Chandler Diaz Diaz healthy
ready to go once you get you know one
more fight uh they announced maybe they
might do Nate Diaz and uh hamzat which I
don't like no it's a terrible fight for
him but Chandler and Diaz makes a lot of
sense and then if Chandler were to beat
him which he'd probably be favored
generally would beat him then Charlie
could fight Connor when he comes back
what what's going on with Hamza are they
keeping him are they like listen you go
over there we just need to have a little
sideshow over here for a while I mean
you know that's not respectful to those
guys but I don't think anybody really
I'm sure he comes out is chomping in the
[ __ ] fight any of them not homside I
was thinking about uh
so yeah so you're talking about Islam
yes Islam you're talking about what's
next for Charles Oliveira yeah because
he be gay too right for that phenomenal
fight Miss Miss wait so the there's no
champion at lightweight dude and so tell
me somebody told me that gaichi's not a
big fan of Jiu Jitsu in terms of
practicing it a lot yeah
he's also rocked and then you know the
guy got his back so there's that and
Charles is one of the best statistically
the best finisher in the game oh my God
the most submission wins yeah he's like
a spider he's a monster I I think for
Charles Oliveira you know makachev the
only knock on him they could give him a
title shot I'm okay with it but The
Knockout matchup he hasn't beat anybody
in the top ten yeah remember you're
supposed to fight uh Darius but then
Darius got hurt so the game Bobby green
that's still not a top 10 win so I would
like and he's scheduled to fight Darius
which if he wins that then you should
get a title shot
but was to sing to Chen on the show and
Chin was wearing that cardigan which I
very much enjoy he was chin looks very
handsome I'm a huge fan of that cardigan
thanks uh Big Boy album that thick Boy
album I don't know if brow shared it
with you just on Spotify alone it's
almost that half a million down oh [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna be there for the the May
17th Tuesday at the Troubadour I'm
excited May 19th my special everybody
still tickets left the brand improv I'm
shooting two shows very special guest
coming in to help out but uh yes
May 19th the May 17th is you May 19th is
you and then May 19th is me
um but uh back to the if you want to
finish on a fight thing yeah please
please with the fight thing the one
caveat there I don't think people are
thinking of so macheb I think he's gonna
have to get a win over top five guy in
Darius which they're scheduled to do I
think they leave that or they pull mock
Jeff and give him the title shot but
something nobody's thinking about is I
like Alex volkanovsky if you were to
beat Max Holloway in the trilogy he
talked about on food truck Diaries
available on think about right now how
55 he can definitely do it all he does
train with 55ers all he does is train
for 55 so and about 65 is enough so he
was saying I want to go 55. I think
that'd be a fun fight Charles Oliveira
volkanovsky at 55. very interesting
that'd be fun somehow there's a lot that
has to happen for you know I know it's
crazy to talk about it but I could see
them doing that mock Jeb do you she's
gonna have to I think they're gonna have
to settle that you know to find out what
macheb's really made of yeah but to not
give him you know to for makshev to just
skip through that murders row and jump
straight into title shot yeah a little
dicey yeah now
odds-wise I would assume he's the
favorite over Charles
I think he's the favorite because we're
thinking about khabib
I agree we're thinking about khabib and
and if I'm Oliveira or I'm or I'm going
to try to figure out I'm gonna try to
figure out and you you tell me if this
is a reasonable thing in my Camp I'm
gonna try to figure out how to solve
that Russian problem I'm gonna try to
submissions yeah it's very tricky on the
ground submissions yeah but when they
control your hips and they pitch I know
a nightmare they bring your knees
together and they rap it's almost
anti-ji Jitsu where they just shut it
all down yeah I'm not gonna I don't even
think they even do guard I think yeah
I'm gonna rain elbows on my guard yeah
yeah pakistanians or chechins that's for
women yeah they just you know their dish
control your wrists and hips and oh yeah
there's a night horrifier but uh but I
do think Charles Oliveira machev
I
I don't know where I'm at as far as
putting money on it but stand up wise
Charles is much better Striker much
better so he can do some damage there
and then he's no slots on the ground so
and you're talking a guy who did doubt
Charles Oliveira for a while I don't
anymore no after that gagey fights I
quit hit there's no quit twice and come
back up and and finish also slow starter
yeah no throw all that out the window
yeah and what's the guy got to do before
you you know co-sign him I'm all in
keeps getting better better can't see
well you know she's no yeah she's triple
so Gage can't see well either wow poor
eyesight yeah
killer so yeah
good fight though yeah and I missed dude
I missed a I missed you guys I missed
two finding the kids miss Chappelle send
off unfortunately I miss King's singing
the wing and then I miss fight campaign
on Saturday Metreon and ramp uh mitrion
Rashad uh have to do it Joe Shillington
Joe Schilling that's right that's a good
that's a good crew yeah Rampage supposed
to be the two but he got sick really I
don't think covet but he got sick yeah
my entire house is sick right now is
that right
I got I was sick before I left and I got
better I think they got it for me yeah
and then they got it worse you know I
caught a little something something yeah
but then you got to perform the idea has
showed up oh did he finally he showed up
he showed up Thursday just Thursday he
wanted to show up Friday want to show up
Saturday
um we we [ __ ] the stress Factory what
it what shows who's electric yeah good
things incredible and it's great an old
school club where you feel that energy
dude oh my God I hadn't been there since
2011. I would Vinnie brand who's my boy
if any brand who owns that place got up
on Friday night I think or Saturday
night my first show and did almost 20
minutes 25 minutes hilarious yeah Vinnie
brand as a club owner is like I was like
this guy's crushed in a room he's
crushing it he's unbelievable it's
beautiful yeah I talked to Joey because
I got busy he got he got too caught up
with stuff yeah I talked to him because
he was like you're in New York I was
like okay can you call me I think you're
busy I don't know yeah he's like let's
do a pop together let's promote the
special and I was like all right and
this was on Wednesday yeah and I was
like I leave tomorrow morning he's out
oh I have to look at my schedule and
then we just couldn't leave yeah he got
he got caught up but he was he was
supposed to come and do the whole
weekend but he um he just got caught up
yeah I don't know but I love him and
here's some pictures and stuff yeah with
you and Joey I got a video I missed him
I put it on my Instagram yeah it's good
stuff
well they they you they sent you some
t-shirts in the mail Cuts t-shirts Cuts
clothing thoughts we're about to do a
commercial for cuts and you're you're
into fashion and clothing I'm in a
fashion and uh you'll notice lately my
outfit I wear jeans cool sneakers and a
white shirt every single day with a cat
it's my new uniform I'm like Batman yes
and so the simples the essentials is
what you need and that's Cuts man well
the essential magazine said something
like they're the best it's like the only
shirt you need or something like that a
nice premium shirt that's all you can
wear it wherever man dinner date night
so it's premium stuff yes man premium
and when you're traveling it's dope the
quality is great they have tons of
variety all right it's uh you know GQ
label them the only shirt worth wearing
that's how nice it is
wearing yes GQ said that yep refresh
your wardrobe in time just for the
summer with cuts see for yourself why
Cuts is one of the fastest growing men's
brands with over 1 million shirts sold
well they sent you they sent you a
package because they put their money
with they're like try it I worked all
day yesterday it's quality stuff man for
my body type it's fantastic 15 off your
first order by going to
cutsclothing.com fighter that's
c-u-t-sclothing.com fighter I haven't
really talked to you since I was out in
uh Austin either with Rogan it's been a
while we were going through some stuff
and God were we ever going through some
stuff so you know there's Ray Longo Ray
Longo came to my show I love you by the
way 64 years old that he doesn't dye his
hair and his eyes couldn't be Bluer and
let me tell you something else about Ray
long ago I had my hand on his back that
[ __ ] is as solid as it gets
never stops working out he's he's just a
stud what a great guy great and I look
we basically live at the same age there
and he's and I'm and how old is he he's
nine years older than me I didn't tell
you I dude I went to a uh uh Broadway
show by myself yeah come on baby dude I
went to miss uh Mr Saturday night Billy
Chris Billy Crystal Billy Crystal 72.
how good was he bro
you forget all like he's won all these
Emmys and all this [ __ ] and he's won
legend Tony Awards Hall of Famer bro and
it's about uh like a stand-up comedian
making it blown up and then it flashes
back from the when he was first coming
up and then to the 90s where he's like
kind of irrelevant in his family he
wrote it
it was so good dude damn when I text you
I got I went inspirational man yeah I'm
at 72 or whatever
when you see when you see someone this
is a guy who came up when you were of
his generation you studied everything
from dance to voice to everything 75
years old ladies and gentlemen I
auditioned for him
I didn't I I auditioned I I did he had a
show that was an improv show and I came
in and auditioned and my one of my
claims to fame was that he laughed and
said that was really good hell yeah
Billy Crystal I was about oh man he was
did I get the part I sure didn't was he
being nice maybe but I'll I believe him
so [ __ ] off and you forget he was on
Saturday Night Live right he was on the
cast Saturday Night Live like I was just
watching posting the Oscars uh excuse me
uh eight times eight times and and Crush
Crush also the voice of Mike wanowski
yeah he's never stopped performing he's
a highly School performer the standards
back then the standards when you were a
performer the the the the when you were
up and especially if you were a Jewish
performer you started in the Catskills
yeah you did the borsche belt so so you
you started if you first of all you were
performing for your family and in in New
York Jewish families that your kid was
allowed to get up there and just make
everybody laugh Rob Ryder talks about
that it was just part of the culture you
let the kids shine yeah let the kid you
look kid you could be in pictures one
day you could be amazing remember
Hollywood stand up and improv were you
that were made were really created by
the Jews yep they were they were Jewish
immigrants they were Jewish they came
from Eastern you know from Europe yeah
Hollywood the the all the great actors
writers agents writers agents producers
Studio heads and Visionaries were all
Jewish yeah nobody ever talks about this
but they were and the great Comics the
The Improv itself and there's a book
called improv Nation about this second
City
that created everything stand-up comedy
it was it was that was a Jewish
expression and it came from the
Catskills it came from the borsche belt
came from that whole thing yeah I went
down a deep dive of Billy Crystal and I
was thinking about he came up from that
I liked all that old school Hollywood
stuff and I I so I did a super deep dive
and I was thinking back then like you
know he had his own show on Saturday
night that's where because that
character was a character that he played
a show on I think it was ABC or NBC yeah
called Mr Saturday Mr Saturday night and
so that's how this play came about and
when you watch it I was thinking back
then think how hard it was to get your
own show back then how many slots were
there there were four channels dude
there were four channels and then I I
thought about this forget or bad think
about back then how how talented you
have to be to separate yourself from the
pack if you did Johnny Carson for five
minutes and you killed it it made your
career and there were stories and I
think it might have been Seinfeld or
someone who uh who went to do Carson 13
times uh uh Steve Martin is that who was
it came in to go we can't not today
there's no Steve Martin said uh he was
on there like seven or eight times his
book uh born standing up he was on there
seven or eight times and he thought he
was like blow up nothing happened he was
like what the hell dude yeah and then
I'm gonna actually come to do it and
they wouldn't even get on yeah so 13
times like we don't have we can't get
you on this time come back 13. Steve
Martin talked about it how he was on it
so many times then eventually he was on
there and it just popped yeah and you
know obviously it's Steve Martin yeah I
was telling Rogan again we haven't
[ __ ] talk to me and Rogan did shows
together that I did his pop the next day
yeah we did the Vulcan together put my
braces in hell yeah put those bad boys
in guys 50 more days oh hey B when we
leave here will you connect me with your
dentist yep I said I'm going to wait
after my special and all the pro
promotion get my teeth fixed I got you
last night my son I got you know so I
was gone for a week Longs I've been away
from them so I came with uh surprises
and they love Nutella chocolate and he
was like Daddy try it and I tried it
hurts so bad okay I was like oh I have
to get well we gotta fix your teeth I
have to get my teeth yes I have to yeah
we're gonna and and we're gonna please
probably be in these and a lot of things
are going to go on the team have your
face gonna be all numb and I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna suck you in
the face you're a bully you know what
they're right I'm gonna bully you I'm
gonna embrace it you're bullying me I'm
gonna bully seriously connect me to
dentists John shobs I have to get that
down the best dude it's hit a point
where I have to come on I have to
address my teeth I'm going there
Wednesday I will I will hook you up yeah
just shoot me his number so I can
schedule appointment no I need it done
that day you'll [ __ ] because it's
gonna take a lot of
a lot of courage and a lot of uh anxiety
it's the worst it's the worst but if you
have to go to the dentist you go to him
but he has to realize like I'm never
coming back like you what do you have to
get done you have to get done that day
because for me just to get in there I'm
gonna be scared yeah do what you gotta
do I see your can I see it can I see the
cavity no no they're small but they
they're very sensitive like that for me
yeah we got some issues the bite's all
off oh yeah yeah
at least in my ways right now I know I
gotta fix these teeth yeah I have to fix
the teeth we'll fix it gotta fix the
Chompers it's only 50 Grand it's not a
big deal
yeah
that's the way it is it's gotten to the
point I have to fix it you have to fix
it yep you know it's bad one time I fix
my [ __ ] team how's your health
otherwise you look a little skinny you
know stressed yeah a little stress you
don't eat no to be honest I was so busy
in New York I ate the same uh meal this
diet is hate people hate me yeah so this
is what I do yeah it works
um no it's uh I eat the same meal every
night in New York it's right by my hotel
off uh uh was 11 Howard this uh the
tiger restaurant wow so nice every night
we're down there every night all the
best I'll just walk around tiger
well your son's name is Tiger so that's
tiger yeah that one's c-y-g-e-r it is
the the tiger the tiger yes so good do
you know what road Asian he goes shops
whiskey is [ __ ] good yeah you know
what I'm gonna name my special you know
he told me what yeah I have my name for
my specialist I told you why I'm calling
my name my special Joe Rogan
can you imagine can you imagine if I
call it Brian Callan Joe Rogan well
that's bro bro joke Ryan count JRE live
dude I so badly titles of all time I I
actually text Rogue and then I go I'm
gonna call my special Joe Rogan he goes
call it he goes maybe just call it Joe
it's a little more subtle Joe's fun
what's funny is uh actually I call my
special Joe Rogan hilarious I think it's
the funniest thing of all time you know
what what do you guys think yeah let us
know
um what's funny is because when we were
in the The Green Room uh David Lucas
came with three bottles of tiger thick
because they sell it out there so he
comes in the green and uh Rogan his
whole crew there I told Robert I said
you know we haven't we don't see him as
much anymore I told him I said it's like
hanging out with a politician there's
security everywhere it's just he's a
different level God bless
so famous but yeah he's so famous that
when he calls me I get a little excited
get nervous no I feel like I'm I've kind
of I'm famous like I'll get I'll be I
get I was with my friend and he called
and I looked at my friend I go excuse me
I have to take this bro and I and I ran
out of the room so that he wouldn't hear
me talk because I didn't know if Joe was
going to say anything I was like I have
to protect his privacy hello dude but
the bottle is in the green room and uh
someone's like can we open this I'm like
yeah that's why Tammy enjoy it and wrote
goes this is yours that's mine and he's
like all right try a nozzle you know Joe
if you don't like he's like well this
I'm gonna have to burn all the bottles I
have Hammer you don't enjoy it yeah oh
this is actually good he goes oh thank
God he goes I don't you know I don't
know you never know it's people send me
whiskey somewhere awful because this is
actually good yeah man it's good and
tell them all about it the next day I
bring a bottle you know me and driving
to each other for out sorry you want to
drink us let's have some drinks so we're
drinking I look 45 minutes an hour into
the Pod we've drank you the whole thing
between the two of us
and I didn't eat that day that's
hilarious we're having a great
conversation you know three hours and
change it's just podcast right yeah to
promote the special so we're going back
and forth on everything dude I jump in
the car I'm like oh my I'm sweating my
flight's in two hours I'm like oh this
is not good the driver's guy pull over
because you know when you're trying not
to I go I'm gonna pull over he's like
and he's like he'll throw up oh dude I
went pull over right now get what jump
back in Daddy was good jumped on a
flight I did two fun podcasts I did
Bradley Martin's podcast That's my boy
that comes out tomorrow oh nice I had a
great time with him that's an
intelligent [ __ ] yes who asks
real questions barely very smart his
success at 32 or 33 is Not an Accident
yeah he's maybe 34. strongest man in the
world very sure we had such a blast and
then I did it went to his house I went
to his house and then I did a podcast
called poopsie
and it's marketed as the shittiest
podcast in the world and it's it's
hilarious it's it's the newest member of
Jackass he's a great [ __ ] guy they
call him poopsie why shit's all done
he's just he was on jackass they he was
willing to do he [ __ ] this is a dude
he talks about on the podcast
on the poopsie podcast and look it up I
think it's poopsie he talks about how he
got bit in the Hand by a shark and it
almost [ __ ] up a surfing he serves big
waves a bit bit like water big enough to
[ __ ] cause major nervous you guys
want to jerk off it's like it's like uh
the stranger I can't feel my head well
that's cool yeah whoopsie poops all
right it's the shittiest podcast maybe
maybe it's called the shittiest podcast
I hope that's his marketing because if
not that's really so [ __ ] funny no
that's what that's what he has a whole
thing worse podcasts
no no
I'll fight is it on your Instagram I'll
find it did you post no not yet because
it hasn't hit yet yeah let me know I'll
text and find out but anyway but um so
so yeah uh [ __ ] um he was he was so
[ __ ] funny though what was he talking
about oh so he yeah yeah so as a young
guy he was he young now or not no he's
35 now really young yeah but he was
surfing like big waves when he was 16
right and he got to know all the guys
he goes out a mile he goes out a mile
into the ocean on a buoy where seals are
and he ties mackerel a bunch of mackerel
to his [ __ ] belt before is this for
Jackass nope this was when he was young
and just decided [ __ ] it I'm gonna be
shark bait oh so you're a mile out with
seals now I don't know what I I don't
know if you know much about oceanography
or sharkology but seals are sharks
that's just their food and usually big
sharks Am I Wrong tigers and and oh
they're gonna have to take out seals El
Blanco as I call him El Blanco Mr Mr
great white
he's out there with macro on his [ __ ]
thing trying to entice the seals to eat
them I have cameras on it sure did and
then he jumps on the buoy and the seals
are like they get they're like oh get
away they run away from him seals will
[ __ ] you up male seals if they think
you're around oh gnarly their teeth are
nuts they'll dog bite you and that's
that's a that's a sea dog but way bigger
and they will [ __ ] the wolf didn't Kelly
Slater tell you that he had a friend who
got [ __ ] up by himself yeah yeah
we think they're little [ __ ] because
great whites are [ __ ] them up left
and right now they they are no no
they'll bite great whites too that's why
great whites come up bite them and let
them go but they also go come underneath
too yes because great whites have all
kinds of scars in their body and a lot
of times it's from seal scratching them
so he got bit by Seals and the Sharks no
nobody bit him he was out there with a
with a macro belt and apparently the
seals kind of ran off but he's one of
those guys that does crazy [ __ ] we had I
thought that stores and go different
well we had a fun podcast and it was
called I'm gonna find out what it is
just so people know but go on
cat how do you feel about your last day
uh it feels sad I feel like I'm
graduating he texted me yesterday or
last week I think I was in New York I
was on my way to New York yeah
I don't know I knew it was coming you
know you just you've grown up you're
doing your own thing you moved far away
yeah that makes sense you got full
sleeve tattoo right yeah
I mean I look very different from when I
first started yeah yep yep we're gonna
miss you we really are okay guys and you
are awesome and we appreciate it oh man
you were the best cat you really were
you were a huge part of the show and and
um you know it's always a bummer this
it's everything changes everything's
everything moves and you have to change
you gotta you got to learn unlearn
relearn you gotta just adapt you got to
keep moving well I'll still be in the
studio I'm still doing cats after dark
oh so you'll be still be here maybe once
a week yeah so we'll still see some of
you you know we'll see you yeah but you
think how far you've Comcast since we
met you right out of USC you were living
in San Jose or whatever yeah I think I
had uh when I first applied for this job
I was still in San Jose and I came back
for this job because my mom wanted me to
move back home since I graduated had no
job prospects with the theater [ __ ]
degree so theater degree yeah I wanted
to see us theater major why didn't I
know that I feel like I did know that
she's definitely said that multiple
times yeah right we all know this about
yeah I think I just assume everybody to
be an actor in LA but I didn't realize
that because both of you are creatives
then
chin yeah it's going to be a rock star I
might sell your merch it's only a matter
of time for chin leaves us because he's
booking so many gigs
can be good though it's literally gonna
be just you me and Mark I say that
Marshall is trying to figure out how to
do audio and [ __ ] but that's how it
should be I say that to everybody who's
like my feature like Kevin Mack right
now is crushing it [ __ ] so proud of
him but I'm like it's a matter of time
before the idea is to use me as a
stepping stone step on me I don't want
and use me to become a headliner just
the whole point me and Chappelle just
had this conversation Saturday night
Chappelle text me Chappelle Lacy he just
you know he decided he wants to move on
and he doesn't want to be just the show
Associated as the third guy in firing
the kid and focus on his podcast
Chappelle's World which is on thick boy
and he's headlining his own dates now
and he takes you on Saturday he goes hey
because he was gonna come with me I'm in
Philadelphia next week at the helium
next Thursday Friday Saturday in Philly
he's gonna come with me uh to Portland
in June which is great I love Chicago
cool man yeah you're in just tell Jay
he'll book your flights he takes you on
Saturday he goes hey man
um headline this new club in San Diego
and I just feel like featuring phrase a
step back I have so much fun headlining
good I hate to tell you man I can't I go
whoa uh stop spell this is the only
reason I brought you on the road this is
exactly how this should go I said I am
so proud of you this is not a negative
thing in any facet yeah I hope you
become the next [ __ ] Kevin Hart were
you were you doing all these things for
Chappelle because you were making a lot
of money out of it were you doing this
because you were getting a lot out of it
or you did you see somebody who was
worth your effort who's a very special
intelligent person and did you do
everything in your power
for free to help this person of course
yeah okay what do you ask because I'm
just trying to reiterate the kinds of
things you do for people for all the
people that can't stand you they should
at least know that yeah I would always
say this can't win over there I would
always say this I always listen to some
of the hate when it comes my way I don't
read much but because I I probably agree
with a lot of you because whatever you
have to say I'm much worse on myself but
um but I I do think it's important to uh
kind of acknowledge that if you're
hating on Comics people who sit around
trying to make people laugh there might
be other people to hate there might be
other people some real bad people maybe
yeah okay at the end of the day it's
like well well I I get I might be a
[ __ ] dick and I make my mistakes but
there are other like there are other
people in the world besides people who
do I all I try to do is sit around think
about ways to make people laugh I'm not
good at anything else I told you when
that team was like you know these guys
are making uh videos and edits and other
stuff I went is it possible I could
offer them a job can I convert them he
said maybe they're beyond that it's a
lot of work
even then I do always glass half full
you know I was like we need editors and
[ __ ] on think what do you think some of
them are good similar and funny just
tell the guy like just stop and we're
good man and also does he know how to
edit and stuff because I'll hire him not
a bad idea no I mean that's where I'm at
in life I I get him in you're that good
I didn't do all this [ __ ] all you guys
if you're that good at it you know you
can get paid some work over here you
know you could actually have a career
like I could use some magic yeah we all
Comics said like if if you would just
stop with an activity and build focus on
your own channel if you can edit and
produce and stuff and and I'm looking
for a really good videographer for I'm
going to be on their own DC tomorrow
I'll be in DC I mean uh Thursday Friday
Saturday I'll be the DC comedy Loft oh
nice and I need a good videographer so
if any of anybody out there is a really
good videographer and editor please hit
me up dude I had to do that in Charlotte
because I I wrote this bit on the plane
about Mugsy Bogues just for Charlotte
and then I was like just something at
the time you have a new hour I'm like
something at the top be fun and it hit
the hardest on Thursday and Friday so I
was like oh I need to do do something
with this because I'm never going to use
it again yeah so we hit up this
videographer that I reached out like hey
I need a video offer and this guy DM was
uh like hey I shot you last time you're
here in whatever five years ago yeah I'm
like oh I like that guy so he came it
was his birthday he's like there's no
other way I want to spend my birthday
man his name's Sam Vargas and he shot
the bit we're gonna put it up it's just
for Charlotte but I was like thank God
we had a good video guy those guys are
Priceless it's like homeless pimp yeah
you know I did a post about it but I
loved it I loved how he shot this up at
us I loved having shot to Stefanos yeah
he's behind the the content of some of
your favorite comedians yeah doesn't
talk about he's behind the scenes he
didn't know I was gonna post that
picture I was like hey can you send me a
picture because he you know he doesn't
like to be on camera go hey can you send
me a picture yourself my wife was
wondering what you look like he sent
then I posted I was like I know you hate
when I post but here man I love you
that's pretty cool he's the best yeah
it's pretty the best you know you make
your name sometimes doing what you love
like and just keep doing it right and
then somebody find you like you just if
you just keep being undeniable and be as
good as you possibly can something will
happen he looks awesome he's wearing a
[ __ ] green he always dressed as crazy
outfit what a fan first of all in comedy
like he's he's the voice for newer
comedy like you have to sell or
everything so you better do right by
pimp you know and you don't realize how
influential he is like when we're
walking the streets of New York he was
getting stopped just as much as I was I
love that like people know homeless Pam
I love that I was like goddamn pimp can
focus dude crazy sorry taking a picture
cream Rises to the top oh he's a monster
so talented I think it's what's
interesting about any time you're trying
to be good at something no matter what
it is
um you're gonna have one fire after
another to put out I feel like life is
that and um and I I think that the
antidote to you know and this isn't even
my idea but I do think if you can just
align yourself with the highest good you
can imagine for yourself align yourself
with it and then just keep at it and
you're gonna [ __ ] up and when you [ __ ]
up and when you make these mistakes and
when you know to own up to it tell the
truth uh take your [ __ ] licks but
just keep moving forward yeah that's the
only way I know I agree with you I also
think I truly believe this I'm not a
super religious person but I think good
things happen to good people so as long
as you tell the truth as long as you
keep if you're a good person and you
always go back to your truth and if
you're trying to strength you're trying
to make the world better yeah I there's
something to that good things happen to
good people yeah good will always win
brother well my my mind always always
win my my girl said to me she she said
when you speak about Bobby you know uh
just you know be careful and do I said
I'm not going to be careful I'm going to
tell the truth I don't have to I don't
have to do anything but face up to what
I did take responsibility for it and
tell the truth as I see it and how what
I was doing so as long as you have that
it doesn't matter it doesn't because if
you try to do deviate from that it's it
would [ __ ] with me it's not gonna it's
gonna get I don't want that thing you
know when you're lying about something
yeah you know when you lie in your life
about anything anything a relationship
you're in whatever it is it it [ __ ]
with you right it makes you weaker in
terms of the cancer eventually yeah it
makes it weaker and yeah you have to go
through that stuff to understand that I
agree and so there's something that you
get there's something really strong I
don't know it feels
yeah if it feels good because it's the
right thing to do yeah you know it's the
right thing to do you always know
somebody said that to me it was much
wiser than me I remember he said you
always know the answer you always know
what's right you know what you're
supposed to do yeah you know deep down
the rest is denial and noise but you
know what you're supposed to well like I
was telling Rogan this and uh we're
talking about helping people and saying
I I learned from him because a lot of
people Rogan helps a ton of people and
he didn't talk about it and I said so
when I got into comedy you were like
that so I was like oh this is how this
works yes and then because I've been so
you know privileged and I've had so many
opportunities I feel a great
responsibility to give back yeah like
you have to do and everyone goes well
you do it because it makes you feel good
yeah and then I thought I go sure it
makes you feel good but that's uh it's
more than that it's what you should do
well saying what got him out of his
anger and the loss of his brother and
all those things was that he he got
seventy five thousand dollars and he
gave it all away and it was in and you
know this is a a truism as far as I can
tell if you are depressed and if you are
hopeless and if you feel lost you can
start by by helping other people you can
start by trying to make your corner of
the world better by giving so I mean
the best people you ever met yeah I mean
so I think that's salt of the earth yeah
and it's important it's important to
keep that in mind and now the mission is
to blow up uh David Lucas and uh dearest
Bennett I dear spent with me this
weekend he has his short on Netflix and
anybody around town that you know
dearest is from Detroit anybody around
town that knows
he is a monster
is that him yeah okay thank goodness
Darius someone says I saw him outside of
bar smoking a cigar that's him
um all right well
great guys yeah Robert some good grounds
I think so buddy what do you got chin
alrighty here we go
so will I am has a one-of-a-kind
Mercedes AMG collab where he's calling
it the flip and it's made specifically
based off of what he wants in the car
damn it it is a four-door Coupe I just
want to get your reaction there's only
one of one it's one of them it's so much
money made by Mercedes yes how much
money is these will I am have I believe
uh it was actually created through the
shop West Coast uh Customs over in
Burbank that was the same shop as uh the
pit my right side I want to get into
music so then is he he's a huge producer
well he was uh
he's a huge producer so it's one of one
but I don't the worth is tough because
it's not an authentic Mercedes car so
those custom cars can be a little dicey
yeah but still so sick so so what is it
it's uh
nothing's filthy he was just uh on
American Idol he was the you know the
mentor for America yeah he does a lot of
singing shows like that now yeah people
like that and he was great and his notes
were so good yeah they're so smart he
was like you're singing this because
this uh there's this big kid on there
he's Italian and he was singing a Justin
Bieber song yeah lonely yeah and he so
they sing it for will I am and then he
gives him notes so the kid's singing
he's you know he got voted off last
night but he's a phenomenal singer and
then will I am just goes hold on hold on
think about what you're saying and then
think how you grew up because he grew up
with like really poor eyesight and you
know chubby so he got bullied a lot he's
like say that like you're actually
lonely because I can feel it you are
he's like say just don't sing it how
would you say that and he says that he
goes Now sing it he does it and the kid
was like that note was nuts yeah man
that's like it made the song that's a
that's again a guy like somebody like
that will I am been successful that long
I promise you he's smart as [ __ ] oh dude
I promised you you play him in a board
game he'll beat you like my experience
with people like that are it's always
like when you meet something like that
and you hang with him a little bit
you're like oh [ __ ] no I got it yep Oh
you have original thoughts all I do is
copy other people what else catching
here we go
so Chris Paul lost his [ __ ] during a
game because he found out that his
mother and his wife along with his kids
were sitting uh I guess Courtside and
there were a lot of fans from the
opposing team they were playing just
like bothering them and it got to the
point where somebody laid hands on his
mother and pushed his wife in front of
the children Jesus and so he loses his
[ __ ] and goes on a Twitter like not a
spiral but he starts tweeting out just
like it's [ __ ] that we get fined for
saying [ __ ] to the fans who are then
getting so rowdy to the point where my
family does not feel safe to watch this
insane that's that should be prosecuted
to the full extent of the law and I
guess those fans were uh get him out
removed from the game you know they
should be banned for life yeah a
player's mom and the kids and wife is
here get the [ __ ] out of here yeah dude
I I should talk about this I had to talk
about rowdy fans so I think it was
Friday night in uh in the stress Factory
there's this noise going on to the point
where I had this I've never I never came
back yeah but in the back it's like
noise and I hear people going you know
Jersey don't [ __ ] around everybody's
tough and you know we got some tough
fighter in the kid pants so and be like
shut the [ __ ] up and Jersey is you know
aggressive it's like Philly it's like
and uh they were Irish gypsies
they were wow they were Irish gypsies
like like they did yeah they they call
themselves Gypsies and they're kind of
known in the area they were awesome but
they were allowed they were big they
don't know that they were a gangster oh
they don't know the etiquette and I did
a whole thing on Ireland and I was were
they fighting
they were just one guy was too drunk to
be there and he was talking too loud to
the girls behind him all the women had
this crazy hair they looked like the
wives from Goodfellas they all look like
the wives from Goodfellas but Irish and
they were I heard later on that they
were known to the law enforcement in
that area interesting yeah these were
these shirts they sounds fun they made
their money they made their money
probably they weren't the lawyers and
doctors sure but God damn it that I had
fun with them and they finally had to
get kicked out they were just too much
too much it was too much it would it
would have been a fight and they would
have answered back for the people that
paid and trying to listen like that's
what the worst part the kind of group
where you see that group and if you're
not just going to fight the men you're
going to be fighting the women too the
women are going to give just as good as
the men are it was like they were a
tight-knit like they were a gang also
for security like oh [ __ ] oh you know
right so they called 11 cops security
come up to me like dude there's this guy
I know like before the show even starts
like he's gonna be a problem 11 cops
showed up holy [ __ ] 11 not not 10 11
showed up outside because they knew they
were like oh these are the guys yeah we
got a situation and there were kitties
are there they were great some of them
were like yeah I thought they said to
Kevin they go I thought you were funny I
thought you were great but but you know
my friend my friends who's getting old
would you like to go and and they kind
of left but they were Kevin said and
Kevin 6'5 Kevin goes they were some big
boys and they were rough yeah but they
were laughing yeah it was really a
little too you need security you need
security it would have been a melee like
[ __ ] and I would have been hiding
Irish Tasmanian devils yeah you know
yeah I'm Irish and I mean Irish sorry
the guy goes I'm sorry I was like this
is beautiful I'm gonna be mad at you
with that musical I know accent oh I'm
sorry
here we go
so Drake posted a photo onto his
Instagram and he read a comment where
someone was trolling him saying
something about um you're saying his son
as writers
writers he kind of like poked fun at his
son then Drake respond back was like all
right dude I'm gonna damn your girl
she's probably looking for some
excitement so he follows the girl and
then DMS her and it was just a funny
little encounter I guess uh the guy who
left a comment said it was crossing the
line when he DMS my wife but it's all
good I'm actually a fan it's funny yeah
it's funny also hilarious by Drake oh so
Drake damned his because yeah the guy
made fun of his son he's like hold up
all right you want to play this game I'm
gonna DM your wife son yeah don't be
making fun of Someone's Child no no no
That's funny though
so Dave Chappelle said that he actually
got a chance to speak with the man who
ran up on stage and attacked him I guess
he just wanted to figure out what it was
about his set or like what about the
attack like why did you do it and the
attacker said I'm actually doing this to
protest the fact that my mom is homeless
now because she was kicked out of her
apartment because of the gentrification
that's happening where she's living and
I guess it really didn't have anything
to do with him it was just trying to
bring attention but he was just trying
to but it's interesting because he also
yeah there's some mental illness there
and then also the kid has Spotify songs
about Dave Chappelle so I don't know if
I'm buying that and then he also had
that weird knife gun thing also how did
he get on stage also how how are they
not pressing charges the LA District
because
gascon is uh Hebrew in San Francisco and
now he wants to ruin La that's why
misdemeanors nuts yeah the kid had a
freaking knife it's so stupid that they
didn't press I would say this though
with that kid that kid obviously has
mental illness and needs to be uh needs
I think he's also homeless too he can't
he left a homeless encampment or uh like
a hostel to come to the show that's what
they don't know how he got it we need
something for people who are not in
their right mind but but you know
possession of a deadly weapon deadly
weapon and also rushing the stage like
you can't have that as a misdemeanor
because then people go oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
do that Drake's concert I'm gonna do
that if this happens on a Chappelle Show
why not do it at The Comedy Store the
improver laugh fact you're like you got
to make an example it doesn't matter
what it is if it's a the crime that
could potentially hurt kill someone yeah
you got to punish them 100 I mean he did
have a [ __ ] gun knife on him yeah we
even get a gun knife that makes sense a
gun with a knife
there's some issues there weird some
issues it's definitely a weird way to
hide a knife
there's so many red flags how do you get
past security
but he got apparently got dealt with
they've really been yeah they messed
them up they're being his ass so bad
Chappelle was like can you move him off
the stage he's just whooping his ass
yeah
well
all right my current events suck this
week
um what they said they sucked they suck
probably well we'll see but this I saw
this I thought this was pretty
fascinating there's no signs blocking it
off and I thought I was [ __ ] high
that's just a pit on the on-ramp what
yeah what the [ __ ] they don't have this
[ __ ] blocked off or not that's a big
problem
watch this guy's coming there's a guy
coming behind me hey yo
hey yo
so he stops yeah even he's like what the
hell also I would back up why is there a
pit though I don't just keep watching
oh
oh no holy [ __ ] oh it's water
oh water I'm not actually high but holy
[ __ ] bro oh how crazy does that look
though dude that's [ __ ] crazy that is
freaky right it's water I thought they
just carved out a hole how did I me too
holy damn that's good that's water I was
like I didn't put that together me
neither no I thought it was a picture
I hate when I'm reminded of how I'm not
house not smart I am but I don't know
that's smart that's an optical illusion
you haven't seen you know there's lots
of questions that people are like and
there's always that one guy like Will I
Am would be like well actually it's
water and I'm like oh no be careful here
[ __ ] all right so Lake Mead you know
it's by uh yeah hold on what's this
Vegas yeah it's my Vegas Ralph coupons I
don't know what's happened there but um
so it's there's been a drought recently
and they're no they're finding barrels
of human bodies remains Jesus so people
that have one of them had like you know
bullet wounds or whatever so yeah Mafia
got rid of a lot of bots yeah and Lake
Mead is huge so there's a second one
they found and then the I guess the
deputies that are investigating this
they're saying there's gonna be a lot
more as the drought goes it gets worse
and it's just old school like from yeah
from the 90s 60s or 70s yeah old school
that's kind of cool oh yeah be swift
they found you a lot of bodies a lot of
bodies oh yes sir yes sir and people you
know people fish in there they eat the
fish it's just kind of like it's kind of
have you fished in their chin yeah ooh I
didn't catch anything it's fine that
those bodies have been it's just so it's
gross to know that there's a human body
that is weird when there's little
there's little human meat in the fish's
tummy but that that's old
killed probably in the 70s 60s yeah yeah
it's from a long time ago that's why
they only saw skulls and make like some
sort of like boots and stuff like that
yeah bullet wounds they didn't die of
natural causes in a cement Barrel no no
Jesus Christ
um so I guess Russians are accusing Elon
Musk of something to do with the
satellites and helping Ukraine yeah
remember we launched that satellite over
Ukraine so they could still have uh
internet or something else yeah so now
Elon basically said if if something
happens to me and I die it's because of
the Russians Jesus this is getting dark
that's scary
but also Elon just I mean
they just lay low for a little bit buddy
yeah I stay in Austin man there's like a
lawsuit too with uh with Twitter he's
buying of Twitter yeah
who who said this oh that's from the
testimony Commander okay yeah okay from
Russia I guess yeah the starlink all
right the last one I have is this is
from MMA Junkie I guess a woman a girl
fan try to rush the cage and you can see
what happened to her after every fight
uh 274 I'm not sure which is that the
best idea there there are some people
that know a little bit about how so she
paid the price dude this is like of
course
she deserves it I'm out
okay she's definitely drunk yeah
she goes oh
and I'll focus in here
oh
that'd be one way of dealing and look
how the security guard just kind of like
just chills
I threw off it's all good now
what's up it's mixed magnet I don't know
what to help with it it just seems that
there does seem to be a thing right
since the Will Smith stuff like this is
occurring a lot but he was just coming
to light more but it seems like to be
this copycat [ __ ] copycat weird huh she
got dealt with dealt with yeah everybody
wants attention she went viral for the
wrong reasons yeah everybody wants and
that that cage is high up there yeah as
you fell on scene now you that when you
get in the case they lock it huh there's
a guy named the gatekeeper go Ching
scary
yeah there we go
is that it chin that's it that's fun
hopefully that girl's okay I think this
is uh an important vodcast my friend I'm
looking forward to find a kid is back
I'm looking forward to it man me too
buddy love you man love you too buddy we
had some more work to do we gotta work I
can't wait for this day to be already
we'll do the best we can or we'll always
try to keep entertaining you telling the
truth hold ourselves accountable and uh
I hope uh if anything people use me as
an example of what not to be and what to
be that's the best I can offer
yep and if you want to talk about in
person I'll be in Philly next week
Philadelphia helium next Thursday Friday
Saturday I mean I'm in DC I'm so close
to you you're there not this week next
week oh no okay not this weekend no next
weekend I'm in Philly at the helium with
the squad uh you can probably find me at
suplex Sinker shop as well out there
that is May 19th through 21st that is
Philly next week and then shopping
friends is back at the Hollywood improv
and a bunch of Monsters May 25th one
night only Wednesday 8 P.M then Portland
is June 9th through June 11th and that
is at the helium San Francisco is also
in June at Cobbs June 17th through June
18th wow here takes at thickboy.com also
uh with the tiger thick whiskey finally
we have an online distributor we sold
out of the first batch they just
restocked it so if you go to
thickboy.com right now you can
officially buy the tiger thick whiskey
go get you some I'd like a I'd like a
case please you want case or a bottle I
want a couple bottles for my home I got
you not okay
whatever you want yeah all right I got
you uh DC comedy Loft this weekend May
12th That's Thursday Friday Saturday I'm
gonna be there I've never done it I
don't know what to expect I think it's
DC though buddy it's gonna be great come
get some yeah DC comedy Loft can't wait
um if you're a Bobby Lee fan come please
and uh and you can you can give me a
couple slaps but I'll hug you anyway
because I love them uh Brea brand improv
my taping I can't believe I'm missing I
know I'm taping my special May 19th
That's Thursday we still we're selling
really well we got some tickets left I
have a very special guest who opens for
me two shows Thursday then West Palm
Beach Florida improv May 27 28 29 I
can't wait one of my favorite places
ever Daddy's on the road and then I I
keep crisscrossing the country bro
Richmond
Virginia Funny Bone June 3rd and fourth
that's a Friday Saturday and then Omaha
Nebraska Funny Bone uh June 10 and 11.
uh I love that place so there it is all
right kids we love you Philly I'll see
you next week
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby